[Music]  this summer you're invited to a magical  place where weird is celebrated strange  is special and beauty is more than meets  the eye hello gorgeous let's check out  how you look today short and stubby  nubby teeth out of full display your  pinkish red got this thing on your head  and whoa girl you couldn't look better  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is there  [Music]  the fresh ugly dog is here the story of  the day or the mum for the year here's a  little scoop on the way down know that  you check out the flow rapid lobster  snapping but only the dog makes the  party happens I couldn't be better than  this  [Music]  I have a feeling we're not an ugly Ville  anymore look guys what's perfection  don't know but let's go say hi  hello must be a customary greeting here  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you